Arne I know you want to do something is
this something you do for social media
you do it a lot
a little snapchat don't worry
okay so is the idea is you film it so
yeah when you into think but what do we
have to do I'm gonna do a shot of myself
and then I go from person to person
I'm each their captor exactly whatever
you want to say okay that's crazy yeah
that's either you want to bag their
catchphrase what's your favorite one I'm
gonna say I'll be back okay your head
what if someone says that already will
you have another one in your head all
right
ready okay we own a Graham Norton Show
and I have some boys
there is no bathroom what did we do
I'm old not obsolete
[Applause]
oh yeah
yeah that was that was a tough one out
of nowhere
now one of the people who sadly didn't
make it was of course relate husband
Khal Drogo